[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's darius rucker country music star
three-time grammy winner
he joins us on the
program hi dan
do you root for a heartache
when you're writing a song
you don't root for it but it sure does
help you write a song
but
okay because because you know if you
grow up and you have an easy life it's
kind of hard to write a hit like you you
have to go through el adele went through
heartbreak taylor goes through
heartbreak it feels like every couple of
years
right
yeah heartbreak helps you right it's
easy to write a heartbreak song you know
because you're writing from i guess
deep down inside you it you know it's
easy to put your emotions on paper when
you're hurting okay
do you
do you put your emotion on paper i have
yes
yes what's what's the painful song
what's the one that you go that one hurt
let her cry that one hurt man
that was i was sad when i wrote that
song i was sad and drunk
okay but i never understood why you let
her cry when why not just
hold her hand i was i was her you know
and so she was letting me cry i was the
girl of that song she was a guy
and so uh
she was letting me cry i guess
was she going through heartbreak or
heartache i was i i was going through
heartbreak i don't think she really
cared what was going on
okay does she know the song is written
about her
yes
yes she does have i met this woman
probably yeah yeah
yeah i'm sure you have
okay
yeah
well that's it i just want to know if
you have
any
good talking to you
who are you listening to right now
who am i listening to that that new
adele record is just
awesome i'm such a fan she's awesome
that sheeran record man that that kid
can write a song uh i don't even talk
with the brothers i was born i can't
stop listening to them you know who i i
really can't stop listening to is john
party he's awesome
he's awesome p-a-r-d-y
but you did something with ed sheeran
did did he write a song with you
yeah he wrote a song that was on the
hoodie record and we wrote a song
together we wrote a song together it's
on uh it's gonna be my country record my
next record coming up yeah
uh
that's with your uh my masterpiece
yes they work okay all right uh so uh
darius is oh you know what before i get
to this he's doing something
clothing-wise
we have a bet we want to know the the
last job you had before you were a
singer
okay
hold on i'm sorry no it's a contest
okay who
who wants to go first the last job that
darius had before he became a full-time
singer seton
oh man i'm gonna say he was a bartender
bartender
you don't want him as your bartender
[Laughter]
you would it would be a great pour i
would say that
but
i'd have to pour him
off the carpet when it was all done
mclovin what job do you think darius had
fishing guide
[Laughter]
that's fishing okay i'm gonna guess
that's a no uh paulie i'm guessing
something not too strenuous with a lot
of women around maybe saw a summer job
at a golf course yeah a summer job at a
golf course okay just before he started
getting paid to be a singer okay todd
he sold watches at a mall and he was so
sick of that job that's why he ended up
writing i don't believe in time
no no
no stop your laughing no no
you just encourage him
that was a good one uh
you worked at a record store
yes i worked at a record store it was my
last job yes that doesn't really count
as a job
no because i really only work like
monday tuesday and wednesday because we
were we were playing all the time so but
uh you know that was my job all right i
was a part i was a bartender too but you
know that was before that
what's the first
uh you didn't get a check back then like
first time you sang
what was the amount of money you got
oh god first time me and mark played
live i think we got
25 bucks
25 bucks and that basically paid for the
little little pa we brought but we got
free beer so that didn't okay all right
yeah all right 25 bucks a free beer are
you at your house right now
in charleston yeah and what do you have
behind you what are those pictures
uh that's chris christophe that's the
chris christopherson uh
tribute that we all did that uh was
really awesome
uh back here that's a picture of me in
the country man it's my favorite picture
of us it's really the only picture out
of me on the wall is that one and under
that is the thing i did for uh
rolando ritchie yeah that's it okay
i think we've i've asked you this before
any uh do it with anybody let me take
mccartney out of there you can't have
mccartney
adele
again adele again yes
yes adele
but how intimidating can it be when
somebody has a voice like that
dude i sang with her
at a thing for lady a and
the intimidation factor was crazy her
voice is
crazy you know and i'm trying to sing
those high notes that charles was
singing you know and she just bailed it
out it was it was like i was like man
can i just stop when you sing it because
i think this is a bad idea
that defeats
the purpose of a duet
exactly
exactly what she's special man she's
special i i don't so darius in the uh
the blowfish they have monday after the
masters where they raise money for uh
junior golf in south carolina it's a
wonderful wonderful uh you know weekend
and um he invites singers you know
people are there
well john daly but he's not a singer but
john goes john sings what knock knock
knock and on now that'll happen
every year every year every year john
just saunters out i don't think anybody
goes uh hey where's john or john you're
next john just walks on stage and starts
singing
but when you had the lead singer of
earth wind and fire
yeah is that yeah maurice white
philip bailey
yeah he and he was
incredible so um but he started singing
and and and darius he wanted you to
start singing with him
and it's the i've never seen you wave
off a singer before
but you know philip sings in a different
you know that's a different zip code and
he's like trying to bring you in and
you're just like waving him off like
nope
he's up
and he's like
i don't do that i don't do that
you got it you got it i'm gonna stand
over here hold the bike like this yeah
phillip bailey
i wanted to meet him
and and who else was there lee elder was
uh the elder was there at that one
wonderful man wonderful man he's a great
great guy those are two people i wanted
to meet that day uh darius is uh working
with fanatics the world's largest
provider of licensed sports member
billia merchandise and sent us some
gifts here uh nfl merchandise for all 32
teams available now
the darius rucker collection
fanatics.com
nflshop.com
what do you got on today you got the
dolphins
i got my dolphins flannel you know with
my with my name with my logo right next
to the nfl so it looks really really
cool that's pretty neat though
for me being a fan like i am you know
how i am about the nfl and you know to
be
to have this line and and it's just it's
neat it's cool it's something i wouldn't
even dreamt about so it's really awesome
but you know what i would love is if you
just had a sweatshirt a dolphin
sweatshirt but then you had tear drops
on the sweatshirt
right i do everything i do every week
anyway
all right do you want a new quarterback
in miami
no i want some talent around the one we
got
you know i i i i think tua can play i
just don't think we've really given him
he's been hurt and we haven't
given him a team to play with i mean
you know i think a lot of these
quarterbacks get a bad rap because they
get on a team that's not doing it and
everybody go there they're a bust yeah
and they're not a bus they just don't
have the talent around them to do what
they can do so i don't i want to give
two of the talent and see what we can do
yeah
it feels like that owner wants to make a
splash and give the give the dolphins a
little bit of a pulse here because it
they're a pretty bland team
a splash with who desean watson
that's a splash yeah that's definitely
that that's a cannon blood that's a
cannibal yeah yeah that's blowing it all
up let's blow it all up there you know
but uh
you know when's the sean going to play
again and you know you got you need
somebody out there on sunday so
uh
are you betting this year
you know i'm betting this year that's
like that's like saying did you wake up
this year you know i'm betting this year
okay are you winning this year
i was keeping this to myself because i
know i'm jinxing myself right now
because right now dan i'm freaking home
fire
i am on i know it's gonna end tonight
now that i said that i'm on fire right
now it's i mean shocking
biggest win of the year what was it
uh it was one saturday i think i won a
total one no one sunday afternoon i won
like 12 grand total
fire on fire
oh fire hit them all
but 12 grand is nothing to you
again when it goes the other way
when you got to write that check
and i want to say this is the funny part
i'm talking about how much of a fire i
am right now and you guys this is not an
exaggeration i went from a thursday
night to a monday night where i went one
of 14.
[Laughter]
it was awful bro
you you were like jimmy johnson's
cowboys you were one in 14. what a 14 go
like run us around the seventh game in a
row i'm like i gotta win this one i
gotta go big here
one or fourteen what's the biggest loss
you've ever had
oh i've
lost double digits
mid double digit thousands i've lost on
the game
yeah i don't do that anymore though i'm
very low-key you know i got my numbers i
stay down you know i'm good if you want
to keep that kind of watch that you're
wearing you know then you can't be
making those kind of
dude hey i could be great long long
they'll still let me play
go and play these shows i'm gonna be
okay
that's true
what do you do the rest of the day
uh as soon as i take this off i'm going
to run and play golf
that's i'm going to like open jack
shouldn't you be shouldn't you be
writing music here
um i'm about done with the record you
know the results
i'm taking a little time off now
could we write you a song
you could i probably wouldn't cut it but
you could okay
yeah i'll cut actually you guys will
install i'll cut it i can't promise
it'll be on my record but i will cut it
yeah because i was going to send it to
chris stapleton
but yeah he won't cut he woke up
do you know that that chris stapleton
didn't know who adele was
so after he won his grammys that after
traveler we had him on
and and he he wrote a song he didn't
even know you know somebody said oh
adele won uh whatever with your song and
he goes who's adele
i'm like chris is awesome i'm like wow
that that guy lives in a whole different
world if he don't know oh he does
he lives in a whole different world so
it's fanatics.com
nflshop.com if you want to check out uh
all the great stuff that uh darius has
and uh that company does they do great
work uh great to talk to you and uh
tell jack i said hello have fun today
talk to you soon
great talking to you go cox all right
all right there you go
that's uh darius rucker
he lives the life you know
not bad go play golf got his son there
playing golf